[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have a super epic episode
today talking about futuristic
counterculture we have Rachel haywire
joining us hello hey there thanks for
coming out to the show I'm happy to be
here thanks for having me
yeah greatly appreciate it and you are
probably the best person to talk about
this because you have all of the right
pieces to this conversation you have you
have the art you have the music you have
the tech piece you have the
transhumanist piece you have this darker
shadow selfie piece and I and I really
love exploring what is taboo in society
so we're gonna do that and its fullest
and I'm super excited see okay you're
let's talk about the background a bit
founding and producing the extreme
futurist festival and instead and Co to
me and let's let's unpack that because
that's already a lot of like event
producing and these are like big events
with lots of people that are learning
about really important subjects so tell
us about kind of like your background of
those last couple of years it actually
started with music I had an industrial
music project called experiment haywire
and I was online Monday promoting my
music and I figured that I would write
an article about transient ism so I've
read an article about transient ism with
the purpose of promoting my transient
miss music suddenly I had a lot of
attention in the transhumanist community
and I decided I wanted to throw a music
arts festival focused on trends
in ISM I called it the extreme futures
fast I was all about uniting the
creative people with the tech people to
create a new fusion of everything that I
loved and cared about okay so what does
it look like - because I want to ask
about this now cuz I think people
typically silo out art and transhumanism
what yeah so I love this I love the
multidisciplinarity of intelligence so
what does it look like when you smash
those two together it looks like robots
on stage setting things on fire
people uploading their minds as bands
are doing and seeing performance art
there are video projectors everywhere
people are wearing virtual reality
goggles going through mazes of their own
consciousness literally yeah it looks
pretty cool I've got to say I love it I
love it and then so as you learn more
about that now you know you know you're
starting to realize that that is kind of
where you want to go into these really
thought-provoking event spaces and doing
these salons and I'm really excited to
talk about that a little bit later but
let's then let's talk about instead as
well on the way you know we see we see
Ted all over the place yes yeah we just
did a TEDx talk couple days ago was
fantastic it's a great stage it's a
great sort of culture of giving
monologues and inspiring people what was
instead about well instead of you can
tell by the name it was inspired by Ted
but I called it instead because I wanted
it to be for people here maybe didn't
have as much money I was the Ted people
but that had those same visionary
groundbreaking ideas about affecting the
world in a new way so it's about uniting
visionary
that did not have the money for Ted that
were on that same wavelength instead was
a continuation of the extreme teacher's
festival we had a lot of people that
went to both and it was really focused
on the difficult areas of the mind there
was definitely a provocative
transgressive element to instead we had
some very controversial speakers um
there were people that spoken instead
that did not agree with each other at
all and that was what was really
interesting to me was that people who
had completely opposing viewpoints could
just hang out together and discuss
things civilly with that artistic
element together at the same time that
is growing to be Buddhist hilarious
we're actually going to transition to
that topic space very shortly of people
with differing opinions still being able
to have calm and nuanced conversation
about where we want to move so okay so I
love the idea of making the really
thought-provoking ideas more accessible
to people so that's really good that you
know you're passionate about that and
then also then we transition kind of to
Co to me that was just recent I was like
a year ago it was actually not even a
year ago that's seven months ago I met a
guy named Jordan gray who was doing
coding me and he had art plus tech on
the website I'm like wait a minute
I'm plus tech that's what doesn't meet
all of the code so I emailed him right
away
and I said I love what you're doing
thank you for carrying on the torch this
reminds me of extreme teachers fest this
reminds me of instead I'd like to get
involved and within a day I was their
art director and I began helping them
produce the festival and this right here
just pen this kind of screams futuristic
robots are like how was how was this
done how did this how did smashing
together art attack
at the coda me how did that go about how
do you feel really well and it was
really nice to see what had happened
after all of this time because coulda me
was very recent the art of its festival
was just this year and I could see the
influences that had happened through the
years in terms of the art in tech fusion
and what people were doing now so the
one performance that really stuck out to
me economy there was a girl on stage who
was doing a modeling show that was also
a Turing test so she was on stage with
several robots and they were all
competing with each other and this
insane performance I refused and I just
thought it was fantastic and yes haha
what were the robots competing for
beauty it was a beauty contest also a
Turing must at least that's how I
perceived it yeah I just said like damn
this is what we need to see more of this
is what I've been working toward like
art tackies still alive and so many
people they will say that there is not
room for art and technology and their
concern because a lot of the artists
done in San Francisco were moving out
because they can't afford to live here
and there they're being replaced by
techies and I say no art and Tech belong
together
Arden Tech are two sides of the same
visionary coin yeah that's a great way
to put it so oh man okay we'll talk
about that art and tech being suicides
the same visionary coin well maybe as we
move on to the monthly salon series
we'll mint will bring that back up I
want to talk about what you wrote and
kind of like also what you know prior to
what you wrote which you made you made
something called sugar warning it said
and trigger warning was in essence just
moving against the political correctness
culture just really just trying to have
people be totally okay with coming up
with ideas that were against the night
the way 99% of people were moving but it
was in essence trying to capture the
Copernicus's the ones that were actually
speaking the truth that's exactly what
it was about I felt like there was a lot
of dough
and the political lab done this is pre
Trump there were people afraid to say
what was on their mind they were afraid
to express certain views because they
were considered heretical they were anti
APC and they did not want to lose their
jobs just for their thoughts um I was a
hardcore leftist way back in the day and
I did not like what the left had become
I thought it had betrayed its initial
values so I founded trigger warning as a
space for people to freely express their
views a platform for a dissident
heretical ideas and yes I was looking
for the new philosophers of our time the
truly great philosophers who were
unafraid of public opinion yeah okay so
this is becoming more and more important
to really get to this calm and nuanced
perform of conversation especially the
people that are in the 1% that I have
these really bright ideas that can't
actually speak them because they're
gonna get shut down by the sort of
binary trap of thinking between the two
sides
laughing so you had this kind of period
of like the alternative right and the
far left just kind of coming into
trigger warning and making it not what
it was meant to be in that yeah it was
really unfortunate but there were a lot
of people on the right the far right who
did not like what I was doing on
essentially obvious them not liking me
for being a Jewish woman they didn't
like that I was creating something
tangible that was actually changing
people's minds they wanted to be stuck
in a little um I guess you could call it
a negative echo chamber of negative
reinforcement and that's exactly how the
far left was to the far left had this
negative echo chamber
of bad enforcement bad things with
everybody
we're just non-stop insulting non-step
attacking just angry tweets vicious
videos and I had no interest in being a
part of any of that I didn't want to
provide a space for people to complain
and hate each other and attack for for
no reason I'm and why did the far left
and the far right attack each other they
have the same economic struggles but I
wanted to do was create something better
I'm sure it was a huge disappointment
you have that happen um but you know I
did not compromise
despite being attacked by the outright
it I didn't suddenly become a leftist
you know I'm I stayed true to myself and
I continued to do I was passionate about
I like how you said that that the far
left and all right both have the same
struggles which is that without a doubt
I mean I don't see where they outright
and and Aoife are attacking each other
on the streets it's a working class
stuff it's a working class scuffle why
aren't it going against the center is
neo-cons in power that are controlling
the global economy and making them fight
against each other it is absolutely
baffling to me so I want to recap that
because we see you can you kind of had
this he gave me a visual in my head
which was kind of a there are some
people at the higher parts of the
socio-economic hierarchy that are
purposely making echo chambers of data
and therefore making parties that are at
the bottom of the socio-economic
hierarchy fight against each other
throughout I didn't conquer no divide
and conquer hopefully never bring that
up on this
that's it's legitimately mm-hmm for a
reason they know what they're doing I
just want and then then the challenge
would be then to help the right and left
understand that we're all struggling for
socio-economic safety security just
financial ability to go and do what we
want with our time and actualize our
potential into the world and that way if
we've rally on those values and then
look upwards yes that's one of the best
ways to sort of go about it but then the
question is how do you rally them
together in the talk that we just gave
on Tuesday we talked a lot about the
binary trap and not going black and
white but finding that nuance that was
calm conversations and looking up
towards your breakthrough towards
yourself actualization yeah I think what
you're building is doing that I think
what we're building seeing is so that's
really cool yeah yeah I'm all about
creating a new fusion of the best parts
of the radical far-left and their
radical fire right for an entirely new
kind of scope of thought which is
outside of the binary but that takes the
best elements of each and creates a new
faction and I personally I call it the
art right the art right is an upgrade of
the outright it is something so much
different from what people have done
before it's a creative insurrectionary
movement full of musicians artists and
filmmakers that are really really
passionate and expressing themselves and
the provocative challenging way that has
been so inspiring to me as a founder um
as a human being is it there a book yes
we have the links the links in the bio
that's on Amazon the new art right and
so lets you you just started chatting
about this a little bit more you we have
musicians artists filmmakers we have
putting together a faction of people
that are sort of in the lower to middle
SES on the planet that can actualize
their potential through these mediums
and combining technology and
I'm doing this to move people up
economically I see a lot of values in
this marketplace that I don't agree with
them I think that some other people that
have the most money are some of the
stupidest and most boring of people and
and through the people that are
struggling the most that are on these
extreme fringes are some of the most
brilliant talented people that exist and
I want to help move them up economically
I want to help grow their art I want to
help grow their music their writing and
I want to I guess have an insurrection
airy revolution of sorts where this new
middle class replaces the old
establishment yes I mean it's a pretty
big goal but I find it to be very
important I love it as you understand I
get it we we also have had these
thoughts on episodes where we go with
street smarts episodes you go on the
street and we asked people questions and
about their what they think the current
state of humanity is and it was very
enriching to hear a lot of them speak
about the truth of the economic and
political machinery how they're the
actual truth way more so than some of
the engineers and designers at tech
companies do and then furthermore is
then they go and speak about art and how
they are creative themselves how they
have music that they're making that they
are philosophers themselves and I'm like
what would it look like if all of these
people that are on the street what if
they were actually able to get their
opinions voices are out into the world
how would that change you I mean I think
that's something
is very very relevant right now say it
that you're a street artist you're
making a little little drawing in your
sketch pad now so you have on like a
hipster that's walking down the street
she sees you making art on your sketch
pad she says hey I kind of like the art
that you're making would you like to
display it I'm throwing a party yeah
right um so the street artist goes to
the party that the hipster is producing
another person who goes to the part of
the hipsters producing is an art
collector exactly the art collector is
looking to change the economy from the
inside and has a lot of power they are
collector discoveries the street artists
yes now the street artist is living in a
loft with five other hipsters yeah so it
is definitely possible to transcend the
class structures that we have on through
the the art class the artist class is a
class within itself it's not working
class it's not
middle class it's not that per class
it's the artists class and we are the
ones that transcend all the classes we
have our own yeah because out of
everything that you would want to do
every single day art is at the top of
that list absolutely that's the most
important part of civilization I'm
without art there is no civilization
it's a joke to think that we can have
this ultra rational ultra reasonably
logical civilization without any art I
mean cuz for me like that is collapse
you know that that is what decline
actually is is a lack of artistic
expression that's to me it sounds like
computer logic yeah on that creative
process of my sound just becoming aware
of actually you know
really for 18 years I was aware of an
attack on the creative process take take
this example as well.you you gave this
really beautiful I've been studying
mathematical sociology and network
theory now for a while and writing about
it and you gave this example where your
your you have an artist that's writing
on a sketch pad and then and then
somebody walks by that has has an art
exhibit this is just a connection to one
node right then you connect to that node
they make a link and then that other
node opens them up to so many other
higher level nodes that then get to see
their art and then only one of those
nodes has to discover the artist before
the artist gets the ability to go and
move of themselves off the street into
somewhere else start making more art etc
so this is these are the very beautiful
eloquent stories that that are actually
so frequent they are very frequent how
they happen all the time I mean
especially because say that you're a
struggling artist yourself and you have
four roommates and you need somebody to
do a painting for an exhibit that you're
putting on and you need some help so
you're walking down the street you see
ya kid you know who's doing a painting
and you're like hey do you want to help
me with my exit bag you know like I can
get you for your work and then I mean
there's so many scenarios in which
people couldn't get off the street just
by meeting like-minded individualism and
it helps everybody you know it's really
about moving the artist class uh cuz I'm
we're kind of up against a big force
that that force is this ultra rational
ultra reasonable kind of paradigm and I
think the the direction that we need to
go in is a much more powerful soulful
experience yeah I also really enjoyed
the computer logic everything is logical
aaja claude reverses the play the art is
the aspect of the human spirit the
human soul it's really unfortunate that
so many people they want to get rid of
the human spirit now they want to create
and he sees like NPCs is actually what
they want
what's an NPC a non-player character and
there here are a lot of jokes about that
online now they're people with no inner
voice they're the the mindless
automatons I mean that's like an ideal
state for a lot of people I mean that's
like the death of the best why would
anybody want that yet people constantly
strive for it and I think like what we
the artists class can do and whatever
our socio-economic standing is is
creative that our world through our
creations we can create a much better
belt and that's what I want to do and
look what I think we should be doing I
love it Rachel
and I also really enjoyed the way that
you tie in you know like video game
concept like a non-player character into
a civilization because when you have a a
non-player character in a civilization
would be one that soul as being
diminished to the point of non-existence
that's just an otamatone like robots are
going to replace these people anyway I'm
fingers crossed but why do they need to
exist if they're acting sooo robotic we
can just replace them with robots I mean
maybe that's like the wrong thing to say
but you know what I don't care these
people are dead inside we should replace
them with robots as soon as possible so
we the artists can stop having to suffer
at the hands of these barbaric fools
alright let's see if I can let's see
let's see if I can potentially augment
just a tiny bit there
what if the out of the people that are
almost completely automatons just
completely crushed their soul by the
economic and political grid that are not
actual izing what if there's just a tiny
little nudge in some way that is that
could help them become more of an actual
player character so so that's that would
be my kind of slight slight nudge and
how could we build communities that give
those slight nudges so
that it would be like not just like get
out of the way you're gonna be
roboticized but rather like hey you know
here's the slight nudge you know if you
actually take this you could actually
really ramp yourself up really quickly
and not be automated so yeah I think
that's definitely important I think
every shouldn't everyone should be given
a chance I think that we should invite
these people to work parties that we
should and invite them to our
conferences we should give them a chance
to hear these new ideas ya hear music to
look at art that is provocative and
challenging and they might just have
something inside them that awakens they
also might be pretending to be NPCs
totally because they're afraid of what
their family or their employers will
think and they might just go to the
right conference and meet people that
resonate with them and they might just
begin to be themselves okay I don't know
we wanted to talk about this on the way
and then we'll get to the monthly salons
but I just wanted you mentioned this
earlier so I wanted to bring it up I
want to hear what your thoughts are
about this we made a thoughts on episode
about the conversation between musk and
Rogan and we and we we were very much
upset at how many times you know musk
had to say that you know I've been
trying to warn people about AI across
the world people aren't listening to me
and then and then all of the news
outlets afterward we're like oh my god
he smoked weed it was it was it was the
exact it was exactly what he's talking
about which is everybody focuses on that
rather than the most important I was AI
really upset when this happened because
Iran is somebody that I have so much
respect for I see as a fellow traveler I
see him as definitely somebody who is a
member of my tribe and the fact that he
is getting brutally attacked by
stockholders
and the media simply for smoking a
spliff with Joe Rogan
he's absurd I mean it's cruel and it's
unnecessary
I mean Elon Musk is a man of the people
who was achieved so much in his life he
has gotten us to Mars and people are
complaining because he is having some
fun on the Joe Rogan show and the fact
that stockholders had a problem with
that I have a problem with these
stockholders now you know what if you're
one of those stockholders and you're
watching this [ __ ] you can I say yeah of
course yeah
so the the you know what you're saying
there is you're you're referencing kind
of this older I'm so excited for the gen
Z the Millennials and even the people
that are being born today 2018 whatever
they're gonna be called because they are
not gonna deal with any of these old
people that are spewing this nonsense
they're gonna they're shattering through
they can already sniff out you I've
started to realize this but the young
people that are looking at Instagram
accounts and stuff like that they'll
really quickly tell when you're
bullshitting and promoting someone
else's product or whatever rather than a
mission that's really profound that
comes from you from your soul so and
when people see that distinction that
clearly you know it's a whole new
generation of people absolutely yeah I'm
still baffled but there's some people
that are born to after snapchat because
I can't imagine like being ten years old
and being like mom can I use snapchat
like when I was 10 I played with my
Barbies I'm I tore their heads off but I
was still playing with Barbies yeah yeah
yeah you are you you are one of those
people that would tear the heads off
yeah yeah I love it I love it okay that
is a compliment it is totally a
compliment yeah tear the Transformers
tear the Barbies make your own new child
toys you know yeah inspirational ones
let's do that so one more quick point on
that I just want to see what you think
about this do you think that
you want a so intelligent that he chose
to smoke the spliff and inhale and not
even really take it into his lungs and
blow it out and be like mmm that was
interesting and although he had already
known quite a good amount about weed and
quite an own a good amount he's like
this is legal in California do you think
Joanne asked him about about like
sponsors anybody gave me that man and
he's like oh it's legal right I'm so
honestly I just don't think that he knew
any better I just thank you very like
just all juristic giving person he wants
to make things better for everybody yeah
he smoked it have a good time and to
relate to people like I hope so do you
think that he might have known that what
he was doing could have brought some of
the share prices down you know I I don't
know but it's interesting to think about
right that you can do things like appear
on a major media publication and choose
to do a form pre conceived pre formulate
some sort of act that you are going to
commit on that publication that is going
to ripple effect cascade some sort of
actions that occur throughout
civilization that then gives you an
upper advantage in what you're trying to
do
that's fascinating you think about
you're like playing chess when you do
that it's very strategic very
Machiavellian you have to consider all
the possible news of all the parties all
the good actors the bad after that I
would say that the what I really believe
I miss that it didn't have anything to
even do with smoking the spliff they
just said that it did it had to do with
them getting mad that he was creating
too much growth they didn't know how to
touch that growth when somebody creates
a lot of growth and people are unable to
tend it to the growth because they
cannot handle that level of entropy or
volatility they find petty things to
[ __ ] about in this case it was that he
smoothed the slip yeah the final straw
but you know and they skipped outlaw the
important skipping are all important
about a IRS as there is old yes which is
so much more important but also guess
what people hate people that make the
world a better place
I noticed that yeah they think that
we're all a bunch of babies who have no
sense of what it means to be a real life
person because we don't have
nine-to-five jobs and basic families and
bla bla bla bla and then they can't look
in the mirror that's the other big part
when I can't look in the mirror and see
what I want to improve about myself and
burn that [ __ ] off and make myself
better if I can't go through that
process I'll just look outside of myself
and I'll just find other people that I
can go and say blah blah blah a little
bit embarrassed because they see parts
of themselves that they're afraid to
express but they're not ready to express
yet so when somebody's very visionary
that has a lot of personality that's
doing something that's really outside of
the box there's definitely an
embarrassment I thought the more normy
people have because they are and there's
devout that heard of themselves and they
take that out it's right on the
expressive the visionaries on Elon has
been a scapegoat before they some she's
just like I'm Jordan Peterson was a
scapegoat I'm just like the Marquis de
Sade's a scapegoat in his
I'm Charles Manson was a scapegoat there
are a lot of people that make others
uncomfortable about parts of themselves
that they're afraid of expressing hmm I
love that it's been happening throughout
history for so long
you speak the 1% as we're circling back
and people hate when you speak to 1%
truth and that's a good way to get yeah
because the vision the vision again
you're thinking solar system
colonization you're thinking advancing
us to sustainable forms of energy
forever and that people are like I need
food today is something that they find
to be a waste of time because they're
not able to comprehend abstract that
they don't know someone person because
to them those areas of thought are not
tangible yes what they don't understand
is that areas of thought that are not
tangible immediately are tangible on a
long enough time line if you put in the
work and take the action steps required
and if they can't visualize the steps
needed to take to achieve these visions
then they have no imagination
yep oh my gosh this has been great I'm
so loving Rachel so loving it
talking about this stuff so I it's nice
to meet like-minded people that I can
have a real discussion with your your
soul is it's a waterfall it's a but it's
really pouring a lot of water and then
and I hope that over time the
environment at the bottom of the
waterfall just becomes lush you know
lush so many animals and plants and this
is let's let's unpack because this is
some of the plants and animals that are
rushing up our the monthly salon ok so
tell us about this so I have a new
production company that I've been
working on for a while
it's like extreme teachers festival
instead but it's now once a month
instead of once a year and there's
salons for people that work in the Tuck
and the entertainment industries that
have a darker sort of confrontational
artistic aesthetic projects everything
from bands to writing to simple
conversations that forbiddens had few
ideas so it's a unification of the
transgressive art class in a new format
that format is monthly salons that occur
here in the Bay Area we're starting the
first one on the last Friday of every
month of the year so we're going to
start in 2019 but we are doing a
pre-launch party here in November and on
the 10th of November it's a little pre
munch and we're gonna see how the rocket
ship goes and run should definitely it's
on his birthday no you did you gave me a
card that was really nice I think it's
got scribbles happy birthday
we could sing happy birthday at the
party to you that's okay after 21 what
if we wrapped it after 21 they don't
matter
rounds at 52 oh yeah he looks younger
I'm 12 eternal eternal 12 motions of a
16 year old so don't don't worry about
it I love the keeping up I've seen them
let's keep the art of a 12 year old
alive for you know forever you know
that's about it's a Picasso thought
escape you have the Wonder yeah but
wanderer yeah explore alive in you the
artist throughout your adulthood cuz it
just gets quelled in so many ways by the
actually i reaiiy recently learned that
part of the evolution of the part of the
societal pressure that comes on to the
child at a young age to stop expressing
itself is when it is expressing itself
through its vocal chords screaming
whining playing around toying around of
how its
using its vocal cords and it's like and
then that's kind of the first iteration
of the shut the hell up yeah I guess
unfortunate I mean people are definitely
told not to express themselves and to
not share their visions because it will
hurt them and the economy it'll hurt
them in the economy if they express
their visions um so I say let's change
the economy so expressing your visions
will help the economy
why don't we scale imagination when I
don't mean skill provoking challenging
pieces of art why don't we so
insurrectionary performance art let's
scale the imagination amen
so on November 10th is the is the pre
party is the party pre-launch relaunch
party much for my new event production
company and then give us a taste of 2019
in terms of these provocative and
challenging areas of human consciousness
I loved how you described it sheriffs
like kind of like what one of the
monthly ones could look like you know a
couple different ways you walk into the
salon on the walls are interactive art
that you can touch sculptures of
different figurines maybe everything
from statues
of European descent to demonic entities
of a sci-fi nature and you can interact
with these sculptures maybe you're
wearing a wearing that's enhancing the
sound for them and you can hear the
sounds that the sculptures are making
I'm suggesting the top of my head and
that would happen if you went into many
of the events and you're looking at the
art the sounds are coming out of the
sculptures you see a painting of
civilization that has never been seen
before
it's an RKO futurist civilization with
elements of the past and the future
blended together
so you see spaceships you see colonies
but you also see this almost like
decadent
sort of aristocracy of people that are
dressed up in everything from period
where to in seeing uniforms from the
imagination of the creators and it's all
this new civilization that is painting
that you can see on the wall of the
salon and then you walk a little more
you start talking to people about ideas
that you've had that you want to discuss
but you feel like maybe you're afraid to
discuss the many warehouse but you can
discuss them at the salon you meet like
minds you say wow these people actually
understand me and I'm not afraid to be
myself around them so yeah I love the
visual that you gave me I'm walking in
I'm seeing both you know people were a
period we're from different eras I'm
seeing the some sort of sculptures from
the past but I'm also seeing sculptures
that are multi-dimensional past the 3d
dimension and and I'm this is really
fascinating because you're really
meshing tons of eras and thoughts
together I love that type of thinking
this is this is gonna be very exciting
really looking forward to it too I would
even stay on if you went like a
historical description the Weimar era
and Berlin now what is what was it
called the Weimar our Weimar yeah
Republic in Berlin before particularly
there was a cabaret scene just really
brilliant academic performance art yeah
that was mixed we have kind of an
intellectual Sensibility now what if we
had that here in Silicon Valley what if
we had the Weimar Republic in Silicon
Valley but with more I would say
politically aware kind of that look you
know I'm what if we could bring together
people
I'm from the far left and the far right
non-binary people no binary political
outlook and we could have people in the
radical Center people outside of the
grid entirely yeah everybody discussing
ideas everybody discussing music you'd
have dance playing that we're just going
wild I'm as you know I'm a big fan of
industrial music so I would definitely
but there's dark electronic industrial
bands I would have a little bit of
everything that I care about and that
much what those lungs are anything that
matters to me so yeah and the
interestingly enough it's as though
you're speaking about our our vision
with sports stadiums how we want to do
thousands of curious intellectuals for
these full-day spiritual and meditative
and and multidisciplinary events you're
speaking about it also on a level of the
smaller community events making these I
love how we are very similar in that
sense it's super exciting okay let's
talk about this so that's that's coming
up in November 10th and then also in
2019 salon starting how about you teach
us about kind of what have been some of
your most exciting provocative
explorations of human consciousness of
the things like the shadow self of these
sort of darker areas of understanding
deep depths of spirituality forbidden
areas that are taboo
teach us about would have been smear
favorites well I don't know if favorites
would be the right word because they
were very difficult um
but when I was younger I was very very
into chaos magic so I did a lot of
invocations I have a lot of spiritual
entities a lot of people they did it for
specific reasons I was a chaos magician
so I did it because I was curious what
was out there
and there was a time where I was
definitely embodying something that was
very very dark that I was fighting with
for a while I was afraid that it was
inside of me there was a an occult force
inside of me a terrify B I was having
nightmares on a consistent basis I was
scaring people assembly because I did
not know how to channel this force um
and what I learned was that I needed to
make friends with that force inside of
me I needed to incorporate my shadow
self into myself and become at peace
with it and as I began expressing those
dark areas of consciousness through my
art and through my music I was able to
come to an agreement with that part of
myself that I had been so afraid of
before now I don't have nightmares
anymore maybe they would be soon as
nightmares to other people but I just
see them I was a good time so yeah it
definitely it took a lot of work I I
wouldn't recommend it to a lot of people
to be honest but I'm happy to have come
out of the other side and every day I am
still
once you say that everybody has to face
the darkness that is within themselves
so that they can best understand how to
find that light as well does everybody
have to absolutely not everybody have to
maybe Oh interesting of course anything
on people but yeah I'm would things be
better if everybody did without a doubt
so so - so people understanding the
depths of darkness would enable them to
potentially better understand the light
of light as much I mean you can't
understand like this without
understanding darkness there's no way
that you can even grasp what light is if
you don't know what darkness is about I
mean that this obscuring of darkness in
the name of light is the opposite of
what enlightenment is take darkness and
conceal it and repress it is a killing
of the light itself what if there is a
movement of the baseline of darkness
just higher up on the enlightenment so
if enlightenment moves up darkness moves
up with it and then you're just in a
different spectrum
yeah nice yeah some people they've just
done they have a huge taboo against
anything dark or I'm negative at all
because they think that it will hurt the
economy right um but no it actually
grows the economy on a long enough
timeline discussing the dark difficult
things actually it moves everybody up
and it creates brilliant civilizations
like through the ashes of the previous
destruction how can you build a
civilization without knowing what the
ashes of the last one looked like you
can honor you will make the same
mistakes
hmm oh man this is so good Rachel okay
that was one of your favorite thank you
Ron for the 15-minute time I thought we
were about there give me one more of
your kind of the explorations of this
more okay different yeah um well I would
say that I mean this is really taboo but
there was definitely a huge and die
left-hand path mentality in the occult
scene where people were saying don't do
left-hand path occult work because what
does that mean left-hand path occult I'm
for the south as opposed to for the
community
Satanism would be an example she so left
him Pathak Oh work is doing it for
myself rather than community it's
considered to be evil don't you
automatically when you do self work
don't you automatically become a better
asset to the community but that's not
how a lot of people in the occult
community see it on so there was a time
that I went to you in a cult conference
it was called P Anthea con and I was
thinking that they were going to be
people that were very open-minded there
just because it was in the cold
conference um but they had a huge anti
left-hand path bias mmm that I found
very very off-putting and sousou as a
result I became very confrontational
with these people and I worked to get
them to invoke those parts of themselves
that they were repressing and it was
really really difficult for me to to
interact and
faced with people here who thought I was
like some evil occultist but I did it
because I believed that we shared a
similar knowledge and now I have people
that were previously afraid of the
left-hand path that are now exploring it
and they come to me and they say thank
you interesting that there is a closed
mindedness around oh around occult and
it's hurting anybody if you're on the
left-hand path you're not doing
something to destroy someone you're just
doing what you care about what matters
to you personally there's there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with caring about your own mind I
mean to call that evil eye that's just
so misguided yep nice that's another
really good one okay we we usually ask a
couple powerful questions on the show
towards the end I want to ask you first
D what do you think about consciousness
being localized here what do you think
about the soul entering the vehicle from
somewhere else what are your thoughts
about that I think that it's impossible
to truly know that that we definitely
have a consciousness we definitely have
a soul that exists beyond the Material
Plane
without a doubt simply by doing
something as simple as a hit of LSD or
one of the mushrooms you can easily
understand that there is more to your
soul and your consciousness than your
body there is a huge focus on the body
right now we have a health and fitness
culture which is great and that people
are getting better for their own selves
I mean there's
is what we need um but to stop at the
body that's ridiculous I mean we have
this whole mind of rel this whole
conscious spiritual realm to play in
that's where the soul resides and that
is so big to me
so I think that the more we go away from
that material is paradigm and focused on
the consciousness and the soul and the
essence of the human spirit the better
we will do as a civilization I love it
you're talking about working out the
mind working out the soul and not just
past the aesthetic okay your body
experiences I know a lot of other people
that have um I've had lucid dreams
before and there's definitely a negative
stigma attached to dissociating but I
think that dissociating can be such a
profound enlightening experience
yeah dissociation is super profound and
enlightening yeah yeah because when once
we unlock the realization that we are
part of everything and that it is all an
interconnected fiber that our mind never
goes back and so and so then we start
treating other people like they're
Divine's eye animals and plants and
earth like it's divine the other side
and you don't come back you broken on
through to the other side as the doors
would say yeah if you open up the doors
and there's no shutting man the doors of
perception are open you're not going
back to your happy little matrix going
back I mean I've seen people try but you
know you're open you're open yeah yeah
um take that red pill let's do it huh
let's do it so back to the red pill
and there's so many different ways up
the mountain and there's so many
different guides that go up the mountain
frequently that we can work with to help
us up so there's not just like one
Morpheus there's thousands there's so
many different ways that you can see
beyond I'm some people they might just
read a book that really awakens them
mm-hmm yeah
okay do you think that we are alone in
the cosmos my experience would tell me
yes because I have never personally met
an alien but I hope we're not I hope
that we're not alone cuz I would love to
meet an alien tomorrow yeah do you think
that we are in a simulation I believe
that we're in a metaphysical simulation
of the mind created by our own thoughts
and that we're in a consensual reality
are we in a computer program created by
some god programmer probably not but
we're definitely in a metaphysical
simulation of our own thoughts that we
can reach right now because we don't
know anything more so the perception
that I see the world with I'm locked
into that and then I'm consents making
consensus with other people about that
wow that's a lamp yeah that's the
simulation I don't necessarily believe
that it's a computer program but I do
believe that it contains data and that
that perception is limited to the senses
that we have to the muscle that we train
that is our soul so you can train that
better we can unlock new perception
exactly yeah I don't think it's
impossible to get out of this simulation
either we are in
stimulation of our own reality based on
material but we can transform our
consciousness to new realms we can go to
new areas and Rachel what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
wow that's a huge question and I'm going
to go with the galaxy the stars in the
galaxy all the planets connected to each
other all of the formations of those
stars and the first time that I went to
the planetarium it's like eight years
old I was on a field trip yeah yeah yeah
the galaxy without a doubt yeah I'm glad
that you think about the other stars and
the planets orbiting them it's really
important all right tiny little speck of
dust we are so insignificant but it's
the ultimate paradox because on the
other side we are a defined being that
will manifest it's yeah yeah well we are
extremely significant in that sense the
scope of everything though yeah we've
realized just how many significant
things there are like cuz say
hypothetically that there were aliens on
other planets imagine their divinity I
mean like imagine the the divine in
alien consciousness that might exist now
that we have no idea about I've never
personally met an alien but I would like
to think that we will as soon as
possible like I said I want to meet an
alien tomorrow yeah likewise yeah still
waiting for those aliens yeah yes so
wait
aliens this said this has been
everything that I would thought that I
thought it would be with futuristic
counterculture really did you you are
that essence thank you like Teddy
embodied that which is important to me I
my view myself as a living work of art
there's a futurist philosopher de
anuncio he said to make oneself a living
work of art and that's what I strive to
do and that's what really matters to me
is embodying that essence of yourself
yeah Rachel what a pleasure this is
wonderful discussions thank you yeah
yeah I'm looking forward to building
together we got a lot to build a lot to
inspire about and you check out some
links in the bio - Rachel's work both
the new art right is there as well as
the music of rate ratios music so check
that out the links are in the bio get
involved you know if you are in the San
Francisco Bay Area and November 10th
we're gonna play that music video yeah
let's play the music video yeah let's do
that and come back and then perfect and
then we'll say goodbye let's do that
yeah we'll play music video right now
[Music]
there's an instant connection the
paradigm shifting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so Rachel tell us about what that honor
way out tell us about what that was that
was so the music video that I did for a
track that I wrote about 15 years ago
called mean enough hot enough and as you
can see from the video it's very ironic
and satirical because I'm making fun of
the constant competition that women go
through with are you mean enough are you
hot enough I'm especially in the dark
counterculture women have to be mean and
hot you know and we can't be ugly we
can't be nice we'd have to be really
really mean and really really hot and it
was initially a homage to a song called
muscle in hate that band called Knight
sir ed had written it was about what it
was like to compete as a guy it was all
about muscle and he muscled in he so I
mean enough had enough was my like the
version of that and that was a music
video that I did with a friend of mine
in New York so it was a lot of fun to be
expressing myself in that way because I
was able to use satire and already to
express my dissatisfaction yes
certain things that were occurring I
loved that and that is and that is a
that is kind of like what you embodied
in this entire conversation is this
going against taboos standards of being
able to make art and tech and just
shatter through cultural norms you have
to be hot and you have to be mean and
you have to be strong and you have to be
hateful like shatter through those
transcendent
honestly it doesn't matter what you look
like if you're good at what you do
and it doesn't matter if you're mean or
nice there you should probably be nice
but it's really about your output
it's about your creations it's always
been about your creations that is the
most important thing it should never be
about how you act or what you look like
it should be about what you're putting
out there yeah what you're building into
the world and that means you have skin
in the game too that's why we always ask
people what you're building because then
that means they have skin in the game
it's a really good book I love that I
really tailored I'm anti fragile it was
another great one it is actually yeah
yeah you you have to have skin in the
game you can't be a passive academic
who's just writing an essay on another
subculture if you're not involved then
nobody really cares about you I just I
don't understand how people that I have
no skin in the game can get any
recognition they haven't put themselves
on the line exactly not they do not
clear characters you know yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's that's right and so
that's why when we look at things like
Twitter threads YouTube comments all
that kind of stuff go and build going
Kanye I wouldn't manifest your destiny
right start your own channel yeah don't
be somebody else's comments or anything
yeah like comment if you want but what
about you what about you have to offer
exactly exactly
much love everyone thank you so much for
tuning in check out some of the links
below go and create manifest your own
destiny build empower yourself through
art and technology go through that sort
of 1% idea like what is everybody not
thinking of right now that you can break
through with thank you everyone for
tuning in thanks Ron for producing and
direct and give us some comments below
and some love Thank You Rachael for
joining us and we'll see you
nice